[Musik]
Bilder vergangener Tage grüne
parteiprominenz seit an seit mit der
Klimabewegung beim Kampf gegen die Kohle
im Hambacher Forst in lützerath 2021 und
im Bundestagswahl Werbespot mit eigener
Hymne
[Musik]
schreckenflieger und meine Fahrt 16
Monate später lützerath abgerissene
Farmen entsetzte klimaaktivisten Frust
und Wut bricht sich Bahn auch über genau
diese grünen jetzt in
Regierungsverantwortung im Bund und Land
schon sehr enttäuscht
von von der grünen Partei ich fühl mich
schon verraten weil sie einfach nicht
dafür ein steht für also was sie sich
eigentlich ausgibt und total rückläufige
Entscheidungen trifft zu sagen wir
setzen uns hier weiter für Klima ein ist
einfach es einfach eine Lüge also ich
bin sehr enttäuscht von den Grünen
Politikern die an der Spitze das Sagen
haben die auch in der Regierung sitzen
die Basis gehe ich fest davon aus
unserer Seite steht
die Spitze muss abgesägt werden der
Protest in lützerath trifft die Partei
ins Mark klimaschutzikone Greta
thünenberg wirft den Grünen Heuchelei
vor die eigene GRÜNE JUGEND sieht sich
im Widerstand auch gegen die
Mutterpartei und junge
Bundestagsabgeordnete wie Nikes lavik
fühlen sich entfremdet
solidarisieren sich mit dem Protest der
sich auch gegen ihre eigenen
Entscheidungen im Bundestag richtet also
gegen sie selbst das war eine sehr
schwere Abwägung aber ich würde jetzt
sagen vor allem auch mit dem was die
Wissenschaft sagt was die Umweltverbände
eben sagen dass wir eigentlich
nachverhandeln brauchen mit RWE RWE und
die Grünen Minister Habeck Bund und
Neubauer NRW hatten sich im Oktober auf
einen Deal geeinigt der Kohleausstieg im
Rheinland wird um acht Jahre vorgezogen
auf 2030 kurzfristig darf dafür mehr
Kohle verfeuert werden nun man annähern
3000 grüne Mitglieder diese beiden
Minister
grüne Grundwerte nicht verraten
lützerath muss bleiben der im Herbst
ausgehandelte Deal mit dem
Energiekonzern RWE droht mit dem
Grundsätzen unserer Partei zu brechen
und nicht nur das wir brechen damit auch
mit dem Pariser Klimaabkommen dem
ampelkoalitionsvertrag und dem letzten
Vertrauen der
klimagerechtigkeitsbewegung die grüne
Führung in NRW verteidigt den Deal als
Erfolg trotz allem Unmut wir konnten
fünf Dörfer retten wir konnten drei Höfe
rettende konnten den Kohleausstieg 2030
erzielen das sind ganz große Schritte
auf dem Weg Richtung 1,5 Grad daran
haben mehr als 700 Wissenschaftler
massive Zweifel denn wichtiger Teil des
Deals mit RWE ist auch das zwei Blöcke
von Braun Kohlekraftwerken derzeit
länger laufen als geplant entscheiden
sei jedoch nicht das Ausstiegsdatum
sondern die Menge an emission diese
Bundesregierung ist nach der
Bundestagswahl ja angetreten eine reg
gesundes Aufbruchs in mehr Klimaschutz
zu werden und jetzt sehen wir aber dass
das Engagement dafür die Begeisterung
dafür jenseits der Rhetorik sehr
begrenzt ist also wir planen im Moment
etwa doppelt so viel CO2 zu imitieren
wie man für das Ereignis 1,5 Grad Ziels
sich noch leisten könnte Luft Berater
der Bundesregierung hat errechnet wie
viele Treibhausgase Deutschland noch
ausstoßen darf wenn die Welt sich nicht
um mehr als 1,5 Grad erhitzen soll ein
Kernziel im ampelkoalitionsvertrag fest
vereinbart die Berechnungen zeigen dass
Zeitfenster in dem dieses Ziel noch
erreichbar ist verschwinden klein die
rote Linie verdeutlicht wie wenig von
diesem Budget ab 2023 noch übrig ist um
die erderhitzung bei 1,5 Grad zu stoppen
Professor hat mit aktuellen Zahlen für
frontal exklusiv dieses Budget auf das
rheinische braune Revier runtergerechnet
das Ergebnis ernüchtern
dass wenn wir das Pariser
Klimaschutzziel von anderthalb Grad
einhalten wollen wir eigentlich in den
nächsten Jahren mit der tagebaufführung
in beiden Tagebauen Garzweiler und
Hambach aufhören müssten um in diesem
Budget zu bleiben die Grünen von fontal
mit diesen Zahlen konfrontiert mit einem
Eingeständnis und die Zahlen die Sie
gerade genannt haben zeigen es reicht
noch nicht was wir bisher machen sondern
natürlich werden wir auch in diesem Jahr
dafür kämpfen dass wir weiter
vorankommen beim Klimaschutz für die
klimaaktivisten sind das
Lippenbekenntnisse sie wollen dass die
Grünen den Kohleabbau unter dem Dorf
stoppen die wiederum verweisen auf den
Zwang zum Kompromiss mit
Koalitionspartnern feststeht aus dem
Tagebau Garzweiler können noch 170
Millionen Tonnen Kohle gefördert werden
weitere 110 Millionen Tonnen sollen aus
dem Gebiet rund um lützerath abgebaut
werden
ein Teil dieser Kohle unter lützerath
werde für die Versorgungssicherheit
gebraucht sagen Gutachter für die
NRW-Landesregierung andere Studien
kommen zu einem komplett anderen
Ergebnis nichts davon sei nötig
die Studien reflektieren das meiner
Ansicht nach nicht in der politischen
Dringlichkeit die im Moment in
Deutschland herrscht der Krieg ist noch
da und die energienot ist nicht
abgewandt wir sind also gezwungen mehr
CO2 zu imitieren um eine gasmangelage zu
vermeiden wir uns die aktuellen
Entwicklung angeguckt wir haben dabei
auch mit einbezogen dass wir eine
Gaskrise haben dass wir tendenziell in
den nächsten paar Jahren eine höhere
Auslastung der Kohlekraftwerke haben
werden und zu einem Teil auch brauchen
das haben wir alles berücksichtigen
kommt trotzdem zu der klaren Erkenntnis
wenn wir auf die Kohle unter dem
dorflitzerat verzichten können wir doch
weiterhin die Energieversorgung das
heißt die Stromversorgung und die
Wärmeversorgung in Deutschland
gewährleisten das doch geht mittlerweile
als geräumt der Kampf um die Kohle
darunter geht weiter wie auch die
bizarre Doppelrolle mancher grüner
zwischen Parlament und Protest gegen
Beschlüsse auch der eigenen Partei
auch wenn wir jetzt hier inmitten der
Trümmer stehen der Streit endet nicht
hier wir haben hinterlitzerath eine
Landstraße die soll noch zerstört werden
wir haben noch sehr viele Felder und
auch um diese diesen Bereich werden wir
so kämpfen wie wir Fülle zur Rad
gekämpft haben Kater Stimmung im Lager
der Protestierenden und die Frage wie es
weitergehen soll auf die Grünen als
Verbündete wollen viele hier nicht mehr
setzen natürlich werden sie Strategien
irgendwie weiterentwickeln jeder Mensch
wird sich irgendwie so seinen Teil
mitnehmen aus dieser Räumung
sogar radikalere
Aktivismus Formen natürlich friedlich
aber radikal eine ernüchterte Bewegung
die sich von den Grünen als
parlamentarischer Arm und Grünen
Regierenden entfremdet hat wütend ist
das könnte radikalisierungs Tendenzen
fördern waren Dieter Rucht
protestforscher seit Jahrzehnten es
droht das eben über die Formen von
Massendemonstration friedlichen
Kundgebungen über die Formen von zivilen
Ungehorsam die ja auch schon sehr
offensiv sein können eben zu
Protestformen gegriffen wird die
Sachbeschädigung massive sachbeschädigen
vielleicht auch Gewalt gegen Personen
beinhalten was bleibt vom Kampf um ein
Dorf das zum Symbol der Entfremdung für
manche des Bruchs geworden ist eine tief
enttäuschte und damit unberechenbare
Protestbewegung eine klimapartei die um
ihre Identität bringt grüne und
Klimabewegung an der Abbruchkante kein
schöner Land in witzerath